e
okay welcome to house housing uh
hopefully a very brief executive session
um the first bill I'd like to call up is
House Bill 296 in recognize
motion make a motion to V to pass as
amended is there a second represent
Howland yes seconds it um any you move
an
amendment yes just like we talked about
last time uh concern was brought up by a
member uh I added in on line seven uh
class 6 roads so now it reads private or
last six okay so representative Dumont
moves Amendment 2025
0797 seconded by representative Howland
is there other discussion on this
amendment is the simple show hands okay
all right all those in favor of
amendment number 2025 0797 H appraise
your hand now those opposed Amendment
passes so now we're on the ought to pass
as amended motion to House Bill
296 made the motion by representative
dun not second by representative Howland
any more discussion
seeing none I'll have when the clerk's
rooll vice chairman Cole absent
representative Thaxton yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Boer yes representative Dumont yes
representative Grant yes representative
miles yes representative Miner yes clerk
reinford yes representative Paige yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative hegner yes
representative
Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander motion carries 17 to zero um
is there any objection to this going on
consent seeing now we're going to put
this on consent representative Dumont
can you get me the while you're
listening intently to floor speeches
today maybe get me that today thank you
okay next up I'm going to call on um uh
call up uh House Bill 457 recognize
myself for a motion I would like to move
ought to pass is there a
second second second by representative
Grant and I'm going to move Amendment
917h is there a second to
that representative Aaron seconds
it got it okay okay so briefly this bill
this is going to replace the entire bill
I think this language is a lot cleaner
um and gets the point across of what um
what the bill was seeking to do I think
it's absolutely inappropriate that a
municipality can regulate who lives in
what bedroom and how they're related um
so all this would do is update the
commission for human rights statute
Equal Housing Opportunity by adding on
line 13 cities towns and municipalities
shall not mandate that occupants of
housing units be related by blood or
marriage this does not prohibit a town
enforcing a fire code this does not
prohibit um local boarding houses I
think this is much cleaner language um
and I think it gets the point across of
what the bill is trying to do um other
other comments on this representative
Howland so does that mean that the
municipality still allows a change of
use I believe so as long as they're not
discriminating based on blood or
marriage
okay okay any other discussion is a show
a hand oh representative Reed I just
wanted to say thank you for the amend I
really like it I think it does very
elegantly get to the point Thank you Mr
chair you're welcome represent pal I
don't know whether it's the right time
to say this but I passed out another one
which was an amendment that I crafted I
think the real issue with the lodging
houses is the the stat itself is super
vague and that's why no one wants to do
it um there's no unlike anywhere else in
uh F any anywhere
else uh per occupant square footage is
defined so for example an apartment it's
200 square ft per occupant the amendment
that I just did took from other states
what they do for lodging houses that
really defines the actual square footage
in that case so it's 80 square foot per
occupant per bedroom and 60 per occupant
per bedroom if they're shared I kept in
there that you could not do uh
discrimination by familiar non-familiar
relationship or marital status and then
the bottom of the paragraph uh I talked
to OS and was going to reference RSA 153
which is state State Fire code they said
instead why don't you put the actual
Statute in State Fire code that's there
so the definition at the bottom that
you're seeing for lodging houses is an
NFPA 101 which state fire code
references and so this just makes it so
much easier for a municipality if
they're going to say we want to have a
lodging house you can say well this is
exactly how many are in it so your code
enforcement can actually do this so
that's that's why I would like to
introduce so will um call a vote on my
Amendment first um and then I'll give
you the opportunity to offer yours if
you'd like to thank you okay represent
Paige thank you Mr chair um I just want
to say that I appreciate the creative
approach of this amendment I think it
comes at it from a different angle but
solves the Crux of the problem um when
we get to if we talk about Al's
Amendment I'll say I also support that
approach but if you know seeing the
writing on the wall today I'm supportive
of of the amendment that's being offered
right now I think that it leaves some of
these other issues
unresolved but I think we can deal with
them down the road and it sounds like
there's another bill in in mun that
tackles some of the same issues so I
think there there's some work left
unfinished if we take just this
amendment but I support I support us
pursuing this amendment okay so this
amendment if adopted would completely
replace the bill so if your amendment is
adopted it would replace my Amendment
just see no no point of order uh a
committee can adopt two different you're
thinking of the floor with floor
amendments a committee can adopt two
amendments and then s has to merge them
into one amendment that would be a
really crazy amendment that would be a
crazy Amendment and I I do not I think
that representative Allen has done
fantastic work I think it's a little bit
complex for where we are in this in this
stage in the game and so I like the
Simplicity of the chair's
Amendment okay so is a show of hands
okay on this amendment or you want a
roll call all right all those in favor
of amendment number 0 917h raise your
hand now
those opposed all right motion carries
um 16
to1 well this is just adopting an
amendment um now we're on the motion of
ought to pass representative Howland do
recognized to move an amendment uh so I
move uh uh Amendment uh 0985 H which
amends uh House Bill 5 uh 57 as I said I
already went over everything in the bill
I think it just clarifies the lodging
house statute and whether we do it this
time time or next time I know that we
need to clarify it because there's
problems with it thank you and I'll
second that so that you can offer the
amendment but I'm not going to support
it all right um is everybody understand
what we're voting on now all right all
those in favor of Representative
howland's Amendment 2025 985 raise your
hand
Now 1 two 3 4 five six those
opposed 1 2 3 represent Hicks 4 5 6 7 8
9 10
11 that's right right 6 to 11 all right
motion fails we're now on the ought to
passes amended motion with amendment
number 2025
917h any more discussion on
this all right seeing none I'm going to
roll Vice chairman Cole not here
representative Daxton yes representative
Aaron yes representative bullier yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative Miner yes clerk reinford
yes representative Paige yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed yes representative Gibbs yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland no representative hegner yes
representative Kerwin
yes m
chair yes I vote
Yes chairman Alexander she forgot about
her State Rep chairman Alexander yes
thank you all right motion carries 16 to
one um any objection to this going on
consent okay seeing none is going to go
on consent I'm going to write the report
um while I'm intently listening this
afternoon um all right last bill we have
is HP 410 I'm going to call on
representative um Reed to make a motion
move on ought to pass all right
representative Reed moves off to pass
representative bolo I second that motion
seconds it representative Reed I move
amendment number
0979 which is before everybody on your
desk okay second by representative
boo okay would you like to speak to the
work of the subcommittee and I would
like to speak to the work of the
subcommittee and to the amendment um I
will try to be very brief so we heard a
lot of feedback during the hearing this
is the bill that creates this thing
called an extraordinary restriction on
housing and it says yeah your their town
can do the extraordinary restriction but
there's a higher threshold if they do
that representative Buller um pointed
out that um strict scrutiny is a legal
standard that very elegantly brings up
that level to say you have to have all
your ducks in a row to prove that this
is um is in order and in necessary so we
took out the you have to bring up you
know this scientific understanding and
quantitative and and whatever evidence
and we just brought it to that strict
scrutiny level which is in case law um
the wording is narrowly tailored to
serve a compelling government interest
and we made it even more specific narrow
compelling government interest in public
health or safety specifically so it's a
very high standard that the courts would
have to use to say that that is
appropriate um so we took out all that
evidence we did say you can supply the
evidence in paragraph two but that it's
not dispositive and then number three is
the list all of the items are largely
the same we did take out the camping
ones which really hurt my feelings but
um I want to camp on my own land but we
took it out as something that a lot of
people would find fault with and uh
particularly the Senate we also took out
the kind of income based thing that
would say that if you're getting a a
variance you wouldn't be charged more
than
$100 um so the ones that remain are the
largely what we talked about uh minimum
square foot which allows tiny homes
unless they can prove otherwise um lot
size minimums of five gross Acres gross
being important because there may be
Wetlands um per primary dwelling unit so
the way I had it before was per lot but
then you would have like if you had adus
then they could require with one Adu a
10 acre minimum for example so we said
per primary dwelling unit uh we added ro
road Frontage requirement which was
similar to a previous Bill we passed um
the prohibition on residential use in
areas zone for commercial use which is
similar to a bill that we passed
restriction on inhome business use and
area zone for residential use provided
that such business does not violate
noise pollution garbage or light
ordinances uh whether a dwelling is
constructed on or offsite which allows
for manufactured um quanz it Mo um all
kinds of different kinds of homes um and
local amendments to State Building Codes
so the State Building code's always in
effect but if it's a 4unit or smaller
the town can't add to the State Building
Code with respect to building materials
or methods of construction this is where
you get your 3D printed houses Etc and
then the effective date is the last
piece originally well second to last
piece um so we're saying the current
ordinances that would that are already
in place that would violate this they
would have um well the effective date
they won't be able to enforce it unless
those ordinances meet that requirement
so that immediately makes those
ordinances like open to lawsuit by the
the citizens who are impacted and then
the final thing is the effective date
which is 180 days we originally had 60
days which is pretty standard and I had
given an extra 90 days for uh current
ordinances but since we're removing that
90 days from that section I just talked
about we're extending to 180 days to
give them time to go back and revise any
current ordinances they have and there
you go right other comments represent
buo representative Aaron yes I was on
the subcommittee uh the original bill I
could not support I think the
subcommittee of the
subcommittee did a great job in in
cutting down everything to this level of
uh wording and I can support this
represent buo yes um so I I also
appreciate a lot of the work that was
done um you know in in the subcommittee
on a bipartisan basis I think
representative Reed um did a really good
good job of summarizing um the bill and
how uh this amendment and how things
have changed the only other thing I
would want to emphasize is that if you
look at the language of this bill it
says town this this bill I think seeks
to strike a balance and it gives a lot
of difference to local control it's not
saying towns can't do these things it's
saying towns may do these things they
just have to you know have a their
restriction narrowly tailored to serve a
compelling government interest and that
interest is in public health or safety
which is reflective of the language um
in the Z enabling act um the other thing
I would point out is that we did kind of
leave a little breadcrumb here in terms
of the type of evidence that may be used
to show that such as scientific studies
quantitative or empirical evidence um
but they those things are not
necessarily dispositive of whether
something is actually um narrowly
tailored or not it's just saying that's
something that may be offered but it is
not inherently dispositive
so um I like this especially I've just
realized on um
line um 29 the Restriction inh home
businesses um used for residential use
that means EFA families can use their
efas in an a residential setting with
restriction you may not remember this Mr
chair but two years ago a year ago
whatever it was you said emphatically to
me as a member on the special committee
on housing you want people to have cafes
in their homes and walkable little cute
little neighborhoods and and that is
exactly why I put that in the LSR when I
filed it was because of your
recommendation Mr chair may I add to a
comment of rep represent Boyers um just
that uh the subcommittee of the
subcommittee was me bringing in lawyers
from mercus and Institute of justice so
we had like I think four lawyers working
on this including representative bolier
and um so the the findings effect if
anybody is confused about dispositive
all it means is that just because they
supplied an Evidence doesn't mean that
that proves the case the judge still
determines whether or not it's um
absolutely compelling to the government
interest in health and safety that's all
okay other comments representative Hicks
thank you one of the one of the things I
think that we struggle with on this
committee a little bit is that balance
of um State mandate versus local control
and I think this um bill is a good
example of of that and really weighing
um those two pretty conflicting you know
issues uh and I think that this bill
does do a good job with that I also
appreciate uh representative Reed's
feelings even though they were hurt she
understood in ordered the bigger picture
here and getting this path to help
people build housing in the state and be
housed in this state um so it was good
compromise it was good bipartisan work
and I think this is more of what should
be happening in the house so thank you
for the subcommittee as well Mr chairman
perfect well with that is everyone every
able to vote on the amendment all right
a show hands okay all those in favor of
amendment number 20259 79h raise your
hand those opposed absten oh no
extensions I'm thinking budget committee
all right motion carries 17 to zero um
we're now on the final ought to pass as
amended motion um any more discussion on
that all right seeing none it's ought to
pass with amendment number 0979 H um
we'll have the cler call the
RO Vice chairman Cole absent
representative Faxton yes representative
Aaron yes representative bullier yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative Miner yes clerk reinford
yes representative Paige yes
representative bores yes representative
Reed yes representative Gibbs
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative hegner yes
representative Kerwin yes chairman
Alexander all right motion carries 17 to
zero a to pass is amended represent read
will you write the report I asked
representative Buller if he would
representative bullo write the report
any objection to this going on consent
all right seeing none we'll put it right
on consent um and with that you have 25
minutes left to your lunch in a free
Tuesday so um Everybody uh enjoy your